to the united states now where the
supreme court has ended 50 years of
federal abortion rights in a 6-3 ruling
the court overturned the landmark 1973
roe versus wade decision that enshrined
a woman's right to an abortion
the ruling is being described as a
constitutional earthquake u.s states now
have the power to set their own abortion
laws around half of them are expected to
restrict or completely ban access to
abortions
a choice no longer theirs missouri
became the first state to ban abortions
as roe versus wade was overturned
this clinic in saint louis had been the
last place in the state to perform
abortions
for me it's tragic because we fought so
hard
to get this law passed
in 1973 when it finally won the victory
now 50 years later they have jerked this
away from us
[Music]
anti-abortion campaigners celebrated
outside the supreme court
so for the older generation of
pro-lifers to see this today i'm so
grateful for them and their perseverance
and i'm glad that i can be on the second
kind of generation that can push this
into 50 states now
13 states had so-called trigger bans
that meant that abortion was immediately
banned as the ruling came through or it
will be banned in the near future
a dozen or so other states could also be
banning abortions soon
the end to roe v wade was made possible
after former president donald trump
appointed a record three justices to the
supreme court
in his ruling the court argued that
abortion was not what it called deeply
rooted in u.s history and traditions for
vice president kamala harris those words
set a dangerous precedent
that theory
then
calls into question
other
rights that we thought were settled
such as the right
to use birth control
the right
to same-sex marriage
the right
to interracial marriage
on the streets of new york city and
elsewhere supporters of the right to
abortion showed their anger
in a country without universal health
care and little or no parental leave for
them it's a matter of privacy and of
having the right to choose for oneself
well for more we can speak to carol
sanger now she's a professor at columbia
law school in new york and she's also a
scholar of reproductive rights professor
sanger welcome to dw
now um a recent poll actually showed
that the majority of americans support
abortion rights so
does this ruling undermine the
legitimacy of the supreme court
in a yes in the sense it does in the
same way that
their decision on
striking down new york city's
restriction on on on hold a gun gun
carrying guns in public did because most
americans also favor that sort of
modest reform in our in our gun laws so
the supreme court is really doing
what its new majority wants to do and it
is it's very faithful to
to a sort of platform which
uncannily
mirrors the republican platform and
position on most of these issues so yes
it it
this decision has and and the gun one
before it have
uh really hammered in the nail on the
idea that the court is
on the coffin that the court the court
that the court is sitting in as an
independent branch of government
well president biden said that this
decision must not be the final word but
are there any legal routes to somehow
reverse the supreme court's ruling
no
there are theoretical routes to doing it
so if there was a major change in
personnel on the court
that would do it but we have no inkling
that that's in store i wanted to just
say in the in the report that preceded
this conversation um it was mentioned
that trump had three appointments and
that was very significant and i think
it's also significant to note that
one of his appointments was actually the
slot that's the appointment that was to
have gone to obama it opened up during
obama's administration but the
republican-controlled senate would not
give the candidate
that obama
appointed nominated a hearing and so the
seat when obama left office passed on to
the new president trump so that's often
called the stolen seat
the three the three uh appointments that
he had were not all
fairly acquired
i wanted to just
that adds to the picture of the court's
um
legitimacy
well there's also
quite a bit of concern that this ruling
could lead to other rights being
scrapped such as the right to birth
control or same-sex marriage
how likely do you think that'll happen
i actually think it's quite likely how
much time it will take is another matter
because it takes a while for cases to
get up to the supreme court usually
three levels of appeal and
so it will take a few years but
the theory is now turned into
actual um the practice which then and it
concerns the right to privacy
and what the cape cod did yesterday was
say there is no constitutional right to
privacy and it was using it in the case
of abortion but there are other rights
that stem from privacy such as
contraception as you mentioned same-sex
marriage same-sex sexual relations
um
uh interracial marriages all come from
privacy and they are all vulnerable
right now
that was carol sanger professor at
columbia law school in new york thank
you so much for your insights